帰ら光生は前のし栄養士で表現した
日本の詩人でしたつまずいたっていいじゃないか
人間だものやれなかったやらなかった
どっちかな夢はでっかく根は深く
このような短くて深いしをたくさん書きました
僕はみつをの詩がとても好きなので今日はみつを風の子をいくつか作ってみたいと思い
ます
iphone やっと買え買えた
心はそのまま5連機はまたネットフリックスを見て過ごした
ミレニアル世代だもの欲しいものを買い損なったが
凹んではいない
現実はまだ
ps 5より解像度が高い
雪だるまを作ろ
インスタに up するためのじゃなく
ただの雪だるまみんなが見ているから
俺は見ない
そう決めた自分こそ
鳥籠の中に囚われていた
facebook 友達を減らしてみたら
友達が増えた本人は気づいていないがー
高校時代にボコバカにしていたあの人が
自分の v 中部チョンブリるに
登録しているティファ多し
やりそうし
選ぶ必要あったっけいいのよいいのよ
ビジネスメールを書くとき
日本人だってネットからコピペしている
図書館から盗んだイヤホンは
雑音仕方さない政治家のことで
もめる時間はない
だって今日観なきゃいけないん
猫の写真がたくさんあるものピッコロは決して
元気だもを作ろうとしないきょうは久しぶりに
お風呂に入ろうかな
スマホなシーン